The Joe Rogan experience bouncing checks.
Yeah.
They found them in California again off the coast after.
They haven't been here for 30 years and they just started showing up again off
to San Francisco and or whatever.
What the fuck are those?
They swim through like little schools of fish and they just swallow them all.
I've seen that.
So basking shark.
Giant mouth.
Yeah.
Wow.
Looking thing.
Just like a funnel for the ocean.
How many bottle caps are those things?
Swallow?
Yeah,
he goes,
you want to talk about plastic straws?
30 feet long.
Imagine what kind of shit impacted like six pack tops are assholes.
So many Olympians have Colin Miller lite,
blood streaming,
either asshole when this shit,
those six got up.
They'll say,
you've gotta be able to handle anything after all these years.
They've swallowed so much bullshit.
Yeah.
Boots and fucking license plates should vote to build both parts.
Bones.
Yeah.
All that shit.
Creepy shift from the bottom of the fucking ocean.
Whale found dead with 13 pounds of plastic in its stomach.
Holy Shit Man.
13 pounds were so gross.
So there was a guy named that.
You see that?
What does this flip flops and 115 drinking cup.
They can't say Red Solo Cup,
but that's what that is.
People out there partying,
partying there on that boat.
And I'm sperm whales.
Wow.
Damn,
that's fucked up man.
I'm lip flops.
I've probably had one of those flip flops.
I've lost so many pairs.
I'm one of mine is in his sperm whales.
So did you see the video?
That Beluga whale returning the girl's cell phone?
What you did?
Okay.
Yeah.
It's fucking crazy.
If they set this up it would have been an amazing setup.
But I'll show you the video.
Whoa.
Returning it girl stuff.
Here you go.
The whale understands objects are important to you.
She knows iPhones are expensive and there's nothing on how far it got dropped
down in the water.
But I'll pull it up here.
It's going all over Instagram and Twitter.
You can easily find the video.
I mean it's coming from the depths of the water.
So like,
I don't know how the fuck you could make this a fucking God holding onto her
phone and it brings it up.
Like,
I don't know how you would fake that.
Oh my God.
Holy Shit.
Well,
you don't look like trainers.
It doesn't look like it's in like a,
you know what I mean?
Like it looks like it's in the water and it says it's the one that was captured
last week.
I don't know if that the same one.
That's split part I think is fake about it,
but oh,
how do they know?
How would they know it's the same one or the other ones that have it?
I think that's,
that's how I initially saw the story and I don't lie.
Don't believe that person,
they're tagged and tracked and by the white whale,
the white whale that we posted about last week,
well it stuck around.
He's been staying in Hammerfest and then,
well maybe it's a different one.
Maybe it's a whale that they saw and not the one that was captured with the
harness.
I think that's what's wrong.
They're just,
well,
what did they post about last week?
Go to go to their,
uh,
the one,
this is where that story came from and that's the part where I was like,
oh,
it is the same story.
Yeah.
It's even trained.
It's a trained well,
yeah.
Maybe you wanted food,
man.
Yeah.
I just thought it was gonna get something.
Fish.
Bitch.
She,
that's so funny.
Here's your phone.
She'd be like,
thank you.
And he's like,
no bitch.
Just like the monkeys,
man.
Give Up.
Give up the food.
You Bitch to steal you.
I'm stealing.
Oh,
that was the other thing that we got Margarita's and we left like a pitcher of
Margaritas out and they dumped the pitcher over and drank the Margarita.
Yeah.
I like to party.
So the monkeys are probably partying on our porch.
Don't leave.
Margaret is out,
dude.
They're going to fucking say,
I'm wondering if the mood hammered.
They get wasted.
They must get so hammered like a picture of mark.
I don't know how much they slapped up after it spilled.
Right,
right.
I imagine they probably just drank every drop.